creo que hay toda una educación por
llevar a cabo
los africanos deben aprender a reclamar
lo que es suyo su riqueza su patrimonio
porque avergonzarse de llevar la rafia
con celebraciones en días festivos y en
eventos importantes
[Música]
y manny harris y franco camerunés primer
diseñador de moda negro en recibir el
título de culture guía de la federación
de alta costura y de la moda en 2020 por
presentar su look su colección por el
verano 2022 fouilloux en la lengua de
waldo de camerún significa mezclados
juntos porque allí donde los pueblos
están divididos las culturas deben
mezclarse la rafia se encuentra casi en
todas partes en objetos de arte máscaras
en ritos en eventos bodas o funerales
está muy presente es como la lentejuela
en europa cuando decimos brillo es
glamour es brillo es alegría es fiesta
creo que la rafia es un poco equivalente
a eso así que creo que la gente tiene
que informarse creo que es un material
bastante noble porque le habló hace
música cuando la toco así canta toca
música me agrada mucho
pero no es fácil de trabajar porque es
básicamente muy rústico
así que requiere mucho trabajo hay que
alisar los hay que peinar lo hay que
entender el significado de ciertas
fibras
y manejes y mezclar las lentejuelas
occidentales con el que te ganes los
bassins cameruneses con las sedas
eléctricas el encaje de kale con los
tintes nigerianos
hemos prestado mucha atención a la
elección del hilo el mundo también tiene
un problema hemos contaminado demasiado
el mundo así que nos toca revisar
nuestra forma de actuar para no seguir
contaminando lo en nuestro caso la moda
también tiene un papel que desempeñar
así que los diseñadores de moda tienen
que esforzarse yo intento esforzarme con
lo que está a mi alcance como puedo pero
reconozco que no es fácil
al final del desfile y manny allí si
está llorando más calmo jan presidente
ejecutivo de la federación francesa de
costura le concedió la insignia de
caballero de las artes y las letras que
reconoce a los artistas que han
contribuido a la influencia de francia
la alta costura un laboratorio de
investigación de materiales cortes pero
también de ideas el japonés yuji man ha
casado ha llamado a su colección elimina
al criminal lo que está en el nivel del
umbral de la percepción lo que es apenas
perceptible
significa algo así como entre a y b
es lo que existe entre ambos son área
muy abstracta y poco clara por ejemplo
lo que hay entre el hombre y la mujer
entre lo artificial y lo natural
y entre oriente y occidente
es algo totalmente diferente
hay cosas intermedias y eso es muy
importante en esta colección por eso
puse el título de eliminar y entonces si
es el punto de partida de la colección
como un cuestionamiento filosófico
si es muy filosófico es muy importante
para mí como el quimono japonés es un
rectángulo se puede utilizar tanto para
hombres como para mujeres y me gusta
esta forma abstracta
los seres humanos no tienen una forma
rectangular pero esta forma rectangular
puede adaptarse a todos por lo que es un
concepto bastante interesante
intento mezclar la costura y la
filosofía del kimono japonés
es necesario experimentar las juntas eso
es lo que quiero expresar a través de
esta colección
la alta costura para combatir el
desencanto de la vida cotidiana a pesar
de la pandemia la explosión en el puerto
de la luz del costo de 2020 en un país
que se desmorona el maestro sastre
libanés elie saab nunca se ha rendido
tras dos años de ausencia por fin ha
vuelto a aparecer
no debemos dejar de crear porque
sinceramente no he parado ningún día
cumplimos el calendario y entregamos
todo a tiempo la pandemia nos ha dejado
disfrutar de la vida normal
porque el último periodo antes de la
pandemia la gente era demasiado agresiva
no sabía lo que quería no se dejaba
impresionar por nada y eso es algo que
no fue nada bonito
por ello elie saab ha trabajado como
nunca en sus talleres para expresar lo
que él llama su renacimiento
es la alegría de vivir alrededor del
mediterráneo por eso todos estos colores
encontramos un vínculo son las
bugambilias que están por todas partes
en todos los países del mediterráneo
y luego el deseo de los clientes también
quieren muchas cosas brillantes con
colores vivos realmente hay volúmenes
muchos volúmenes esta vez muchas telas
como el tafetán y el satén
en esta oportunidad creo que hay muchas
novedades en la forma de abordar creo
que provocará mucha envidia a nuestros
clientes
un desfile de alta costura termina
tradicionalmente con un vestido de novia
eli saab se viste con una cola de 20
metros cuadrados adornada con cristales
brillantes para redescubrir la
embriaguez de la alegría de vivir
[Música]